[Música]
bueno muchas gracias creo que la
presentación ha sido más larga que la
ponencia no la escuchado tantas cosas no
no en fin
bueno uno dos tres talento y cultura ese
es el título de la presentación que
quiero compartir con ustedes hoy talento
y cultura como creo que ha dicho la
compañera pues el departamento al que yo
pertenezco es lo que me dedico día a día
y es en el lío que estoy metido casi
todos los días en mí en mi carrera
profesional y uno dos tres el número de
preguntas que también quiero reflexionar
con ustedes
y compartir hoy aquí la primera que creo
que es la más complicada de explicar es
intentar decirles bajo mi humilde
opinión cómo se han transformado los
departamentos de personas y de recursos
humanos en los últimos tiempos la
segunda que es la que más me hacen es
que pinta un ingeniero industrial en la
gestión de las personas y la tercera
posiblemente la más interesante es que
hago hoy dando una charla aquí para la
primera que como les digo es la más la
más complicada me gustaría contarles una
anécdota una anécdota personal y para
eso les les presento a alguien que es mi
madre vale mi madre se llama anna marie
es de cádiz y vino aquí hace 37 años que
es la justo que yo tengo y bueno les
cuento esto porque aproximadamente hace
cuatro años pues mi carrera profesional
dio un giro bastante importante yo
llevaba a la parte de
de formación comercial y posventa dentro
de una organización y de repente en
aquel entonces el ceo de la compañía y
hoy presidente pues me dijo que a partir
de ese momento iba a ser el director de
recursos humanos me lo dijo porque ni me
pregunto me lo dijo de hecho fue una
entrevista que recuerdo como si fuera
esta mañana y algunos por aquí estuvo
incluso y duró casi tres horas y bueno
de ahí que les presenté a mi madre
porque cuando me fui a mi casa fue a la
primera persona que vi y me vio llegar y
como todas las madres me dijo qué te
pasa en la cara están muy nerviosos y
bueno resulta que sí estaba muy nervioso
y le llama así porque creo que me han
ascendido en la empresa y ahora soy el
director de recursos humanos de un grupo
tan nervioso estamos bien felicidades y
me dijo qué vas a hacer es que no sé qué
hacer me han pedido que transforme las
personas de la empresa y no sé por dónde
empezar
entonces le conté cómo veo yo los
departamentos de personas dentro
de las organizaciones y le empezó
hablando de la administración de
personales para mí los departamentos de
recursos humanos se diferencia en una
cosa es muy importante y es quién es tu
cliente en un principio lo que yo
conocía como el departamento de
administración de personal el cliente
era siempre o es siempre alguien que
tiene que ser tu cliente que es la
legislación y la administración algo muy
bueno pero bueno creo que no es el
concepto más adecuado tras eso pues
empezar a conocer lo que son los
departamentos de recursos humanos qué
bueno creo que se mejoró mucho porque ya
no sólo trabajas para la administración
y la legislación sino que también lo
haces para lo importante dentro una
compañía que son las personas
bueno pero todos hemos dicho alguna vez
que ni queremos ser un número ni
queremos ser un recurso entonces dentro
de las organizaciones entonces creo que
no es del todo completo a partir de ahí
pues hemos visto y yo lo he vivido
departamentos que se llaman
departamentos de personas y creo que va
un poco más encaminado porque ponemos el
foco en el talento que tenemos dentro de
las compañías y así nos llamamos
departamento de personas de repente
llegó el dinero y llegó el marketing
también a los recursos humanos y
entonces cambiamos personas por people
porque en inglés siempre mola más vale
entonces éramos pues people en la
empresa que sea yo en la mía era así y
como no me daba mucho así incluso lo
pusimos inclusiva con tres puntos y un
máster porque empezamos a salir las
redes sociales corporativas y si eras
atrevidos como envasada a mí pues te
ponía un corazón en el final entonces en
la conversación con mi madre que está
empezando a usar facebook andaba un poco
perdida entonces
lo que para mí realmente representa un
departamento de personas de talento o de
recursos humanos o el nombre que le
queramos dar que es talento y cultura y
aquí incluso me lo pone más fácil para
explicar que es a lo que me dedico yo y
mis compañeros y compañeras dentro de la
empresa por un lado el talento y qué es
el talento pues bueno el talento está
razonada y muy fácil de explicar además
es uno de mis deportistas favoritos rafa
nadal no sé si conocen la historia y
espero saber mela bien
e intentos el futbolista en su día pero
no pudo no solo porque era muy malo sino
porque además se lesionó una rodilla
cuando se lesionó la rodilla pues pasó a
jugar el al tenis ya utilizar los brazos
bueno se descubrió que era muy bueno y
tenía un talento para la raqueta es
decir les quiero decir
que si desarrollamos y potenciamos un
talento pues podemos generar una
estrella como hoy es rafa nadal en el
tenis otro que me representa
es una surfer a que hamilton esta chica
no si la conocen pero participa en el
circuito mundial de surf es de las
mejores del mundo como rafa nació para
hacer surf era nació para el mar lo que
pasa que ella encima tuvo un problema
diferente una lesión un poco más grave y
es con tiburón tigre le arrancó el brazo
izquierdo al mes del accidente ya estaba
surfeando bueno con esto quiero decirles
que también hay que potenciar y
desarrollar el talento pero también es
muy importante el esfuerzo y la
implicación y hasta chicas pues les
sobran
venimos a hablar de las organizaciones
vale entonces bueno aquí tiro de la
segunda pregunta qué hace un ingeniero
en la gestión de personas oa qué
me dedico yo con mi perfil es también la
carrera ingeniería me explicaron que
todo tiene que tener un proceso y que
todos los procesos son mejorables cada
día siempre tenemos que mejorar reiterar
para que todo salga correctamente que
cuatro puntos veo yo en un proceso o
creo que existen en un proceso los
procesos visto por un cliente o por un
usuario pueden ser o muy difíciles o muy
fáciles
también pueden ser muy amigables pero
muy poco amigable
o lo que es lo mismo muy poco intuitivo
y muy intuitivo que ocurre en las
empresas que ocurre cuando gestionas el
talento pues bueno yo y mis compañeros y
compañeras lo que queremos es situar
todo lo que tiene que ver con talento en
la parte superior derecha de la matriz
hay millones de procesos que tienen que
estar relacionados con el talento dentro
de una empresa y todo se puede mejorar
yo les traigo tres que son los que a
nosotros nos obsesionan uno es la
experiencia
la experiencia en todas las empresas se
ahora se habla de la experiencia del
cliente pero la verdadera experiencia
está en la experiencia del empleado
donde empieza la experiencia de un
empleado pues en una playa en una
biblioteca
en una discoteca en una empresa que es
competidora nuestra cuando terminas tu
carrera empieza cuando alguien se
interesa por tu organización por tu
empresa en el momento que se interesa
por una vacante o está en tu página web
se está interesando por ti y ahí empieza
la experiencia hasta que sale de la
empresa porque o bien él lo decide o
porque la empresa lo decide y en todo
ese tiempo que espero que siempre será
muy largo pues se vive una serie de
cosas que hay que cuidar y hay que
colocar arriba a la derecha el siguiente
que creo que es muy importante también
es el conocimiento la gestión del
conocimiento del talento el talento
necesita aprender necesita desarrollarse
y la empresa con él por eso es muy
importante tener siempre planes de
formación que están adaptados a
necesidades de los usuarios que son
nuestros empleados y a las necesidades
que vive la organización en ese momento
y no siempre se hacen y por supuesto el
desarrollo el desarrollo profesional
dentro de las empresas
y el último
los recursos y los entornos que ponemos
a disposición de nuestro talento y este
también es muy importante
me decían que hiciéramos referencia a lo
que estamos viviendo a la época de
incertidumbre al último año y medio ya
que va para dos se pueden imaginar las
empresas que han puesto antes de la
pandemia los recursos y el entorno
necesario para que la gente pueda
trabajar porque no lo ha hecho
seguramente ahora lo está pagando
después del talento venía explicarle a
mi madre
la cultura algo más complicado por la
cultura tiene mucha mucha tela pero
bueno hay una frase que a mí me gusta
mucho que dice que la cultura se
desayuna a la estrategia la estrategia
yo la entiendo como nuestro objetivo
nuestro rumbo que queremos conseguir y
la cultura es como lo queremos hacer y
aquí me vuelvo a estos dos años cuantas
estrategias hemos tenido cuántos
objetivos hemos tenido y cuanto a poca
cultura hemos tenido muchas veces para
gestionar ese camino hacia conseguir lo
que queremos es difícil de explicar con
esta frase entonces le decía mamá en la
parte de la cultura hay algo que creo
que a mí me llama la atención y es la
música la música
puede sonar como bien saben o muy baja o
muy alto pues con la cultura en la
empresa pasa lo mismo se puede quedar en
un despacho en el consejo de dirección
en una reunión de los directores o puede
llegar a todas las partes de la compañía
y luego además puede sonar desafinada o
afinada que eso lo dejo para que lo
piense cuando la cultura dentro nuestra
empresa está desafinada cuando la música
suena más muy baja y muy mal y hay tres
cosas que también les traigo de cultura
que para mí son las más importantes la
más llamativa son los valores que no sé
si se ve porque están muy arriba los
valores son en una empresa no lo que
pone en la página web no lo que
escribimos y desarrollamos sino los
valores son el café por la mañana el
buenos días el adiós la reunión con mi
compañero la reunión con mi jefe el
saludar cómo se respira la empresa esos
son los valores y también deben sonar
alto y afinado por eso tiene que estar
en la parte derecha de la matriz
el siguiente los líderes algo muy
importante dentro de la empresa sino lo
más importante los cargos intermedios
dentro de las compañías que pueden hacer
tu mejor día o tu peor día pues eso
tiene que formar parte de la cultura que
se repite se respira en las empresas
otra vez este año y medio o estos dos
años hemos tenido los mejores líderes
hemos sido auto liderado de la mejor
forma para conseguir los objetivos y el
rumbo que nos han marcado pues bueno en
eso trabajamos y por último una nueva
cultura que ya no es tan nueva que es la
cultura de la tecnología y del dato que
encima hoy creo que se ha comentado
bastante aquí la tecnología no existe
ninguna compañía que no necesite la
tecnología para avanzar
es cierto que necesitamos
utilizar de la mejor forma esta
tecnología para no equivocarnos y por
supuesto el dato tomar decisiones en
función de lo que conocemos de lo que
podemos medir está la dejado para la
última justo pues porque creo que es
algo que nos falta a los que trabajamos
en la gestión de personas y es pensar en
la tecnología y en el dato algo que
siempre hemos tenido a las puertas pues
yo creo que con la tecnología también
podemos medir la cultura y también
podemos medir el desarrollo del talento
por eso es muy importante y el dato pues
se puede imaginar que es de un
departamento de recursos humanos y de
personas sin datos porque muchas veces
como escucho muy a menudo tomamos
decisiones en función de opiniones y no
de datos en fin estas son las
diapositivas con las que a mi madre le
explico más o menos lo que hago y me
sigue preguntando que que hago pero
bueno los intentos creo que son dos
ejemplos muy claros que por lo menos a
mí me sirve incluso para situarme cada
día en la empresa porque todo lo que
hagamos lo debemos situar en cuadrantes
y bueno la última pregunta porque le
había prometido que no les iba a aburrir
es que hago en una charla usted
y esta es sencilla pero un poco
diferente y es que yo siempre he sido un
enganchado de este tipo de charlas he
aprendido mucho he compartido mucho y
bueno para mí es una ilusión y agradezco
a la organización que hayan contado
conmigo porque se acerca a un sueño
y cumplir así que les animo a que todos
sueños también se pueden cumplir y bueno
yo le dije que iba a ser rápido para
terminar si les doy las gracias además
ha añadido alguien especial para mí que
es mía mía es mi perrita me acompaña a
todos los lados y la verdad que es una
persona que tiene muchos valores que
transmite culturas y que además tiene un
buen talento como compañera de hecho la
voy a invitar porque es la que se ha
tragado esta presentación varias veces
verdad así que bueno
[Aplausos]